provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Okay, shall
we start on this review session?
And I'm figuring that the main
topic would be finite elements,
because the last review session
focused on the truss problems.
One note about codes.
So probably you've looked
at the CSE page, where
some codes that we had
earlier are put there,
section by section.
Now people are
contributing a truss code,
so I don't see any reason
why that shouldn't eventually
go onto the CSE page.
If you have other codes,
like finite element
codes, for specific
problems, think about,
if you get them
with some comments,
if they're appropriate
to go on the CSE page,
that's certainly a possibility.
And the homework
solutions, which
are now on the 18.085 page,
will migrate to the CSE page,
for their permanent status.
So that's just to say, this
is a page that's growing,
and any help is
very, very welcome.
So, I'm ready for questions
about finite elements, maybe
specifically, or
other things, too.
Thanks.
Yeah, lots to say
about finite elements.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: So
this is finite elements
for heat transfer.
Okay, which course was that?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Okay.
Right, free or fixed
boundary conditions.
Okay, I see.
So the question is, how do
we handle boundary conditions
which are not
something equal zero,
but something equals a
constant, or something is given.
Right.
Good point.
So, somehow when
we're given numbers,
they're going to--
Input, source terms,
they're going to show up
on the right-hand side.
Right?
Eventually, they'll be part
of the right side vector F,
in some appropriate way.
So that we'll be solving
KU=F, where U will represent
the unknown displacements,
whatever they are
in the problem.
So let's see, what do I say
about getting things correctly
onto the right hand side?
My general thought would
be, so we create a matrix
that I might call K_0.
That's a matrix where
we have not knocked
out any rows or columns.
It's probably, almost
surely singular.
It's got all possible
unknowns, even those that
are not actually unknown,
associated with the columns
of that matrix.
So we start with that.
Start with that.
Okay.
Now, suppose-- Let's take
things in order then.
Suppose U_7 is set to zero.
So what will that
do to our matrix K?
How do we-- Having
created this matrix K,
let's suppose we've got
it, how do we include in it
the boundary condition U_7=0?
Okay, well that column of
the matrix, the column number
seven, I guess, or the column
corresponding to that unknown,
is going to go.
Is that right?
Yes.
That's what we've done,
we've struck out a column.
And we should also, I
guess, strike out a row.
We would really like to end up
with symmetric, and normally
positive definite, matrices.
So this would be a column
row-- I'm speaking roughly,
because I didn't have advanced
preparation on this question.
So column/row removed.
Okay, now suppose
U_7 has some value
A. How do we account for that?
So what do we do?
U_7 isn't still unknown, so
we want to get that column out
of our matrix.
But something has to happen
to account for the A.
So what is that?
So my picture is that in my
original K_0, which had--
My original K_0, and then all
the U's equal all the F's.
So this had a column for
everybody, including U_7.
So there was the other
U's, including U_7,
and these F's maybe came
from body forces, stuff
inside the interval.
Now here comes perhaps
a boundary condition.
Oh, I wrote it in
the middle anyway.
So what happens
when I set U_7 to A?
So I think that becomes,
I strike out that unknown,
strike out that column,
strike out that row, I think.
But what should happen?
How does the A come in?
Well that A multiplied
that column, right?
That A multiplied-- This
equation expressed equilibrium.
Those equations were all valid.
You could say we haven't imposed
the boundary conditions yet.
Now when we do-- So that
A multiplies that column.
So what happens now, what
do you think should I do?
It seems to me that I should
bring A times that column over
to the other side, with
a minus, of course,
because I put it on the
other side of the equation.
So I would think I do
this: A times column seven.
I think.
I think that would seem right.
Now you're going to ask about --
you unfortunately did ask about
-- a free condition.
Say u'-- So what
am I going to do?
I'd better think here.
What's cooking now?
So I could prescribe u',
let me say one, equal zero,
let's just think about that.
What happens with that?
Hmm.
So let's see.
Well, so u' was
not one of our U's,
so this isn't just simply,
OK assign a value, zero or A,
to a U. u' being zero, well that
came in as a natural boundary
condition, right?
If I remember my own lectures.
So that u'=0 came in as a
natural boundary condition.
And what did that mean?
That meant that I don't
have to impose it.
The finite element method
should deal with that.
This is really our w.
Our dual unknown, w.
It's better to think of it as w.
Maybe cu' is what it is, but
it's good to think of it as w.
Okay, so I think of
that as something we
don't have to impose.
In other words, the
way I'm thinking now,
I don't have to
think about that.
I've got trial functions
whose combinations will get
me close to the correct answer.
And the equations will
naturally do that.
Okay, now you're asking
this serious question?
What about w=A?
What about that?
Or B. Let me make it
something different.
Okay.
Let me say right off, without
having prepared a good answer
to this question, I'm not going
to do it as well as I should.
So maybe what my real
answer should be,
let me think through the best
answer and do it another time.
It's going to contribute
some term, some new term.
When we integrated by parts
to get to the weak form,
this guy just showed up.
And up to now, we've just
assume that B was zero,
and we didn't worry.
But somewhere in that
integration by parts,
a term is going to appear
that I can't just throw away.
Yeah.
So let me think about
that more properly.
I mean that's a
very good question,
and the lectures
didn't allow for that.
Okay, if I can put that one
off and give you a good answer.
Because it deserves it.
Okay, other questions.
Other discussion.
Yeah, you have one?
AUDIENCE: I have maybe
a silly question.
PROFESSOR STRANG: You
have a silly question?
Good.
Okay.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Compare finite elements
with finite differences.
Okay, yeah.
That's not a silly question.
So finite differences
is certainly
associated with
values at a mesh.
Here would be one
way to think of it.
So the question is,
finite elements,
finite element method versus
finite difference method.
And of course, there
are other methods, too.
Okay, I could think
about finite differences.
One way of seeing
them together is,
I could think about finite
differences this way.
My test functions, you
remember, which I always
integrate against.
Instead of taking
the test functions
to be the trial functions,
which is giving us
our standard finite element K,
I could take the test functions
to be delta functions.
What would happen
if I take the-- So,
again just think about that.
Suppose my solution U is
a combination of the phis,
as always.
As before.
But my test functions, V, are
delta functions at mesh points.
Because up to now,
we've always taking
the V's to be the
same as the phis.
So the V_i, the test functions,
and I'll want n of them.
I'll have n mesh points.
My n mesh points, those will
give me n delta functions,
n test functions.
And what happens then, when
I look at the integral?
The finite element deal
says, take the weak form.
Well, OK.
And you'll see why, I'm going
to take the weak form before I
take the integration by parts.
Why is that?
Because when I
integrated by parts,
do you remember
what the effect was?
The effect was to take
a derivative off of U
and throw it onto
the test function V.
But now that I'm choosing delta
functions for the V's, it's
too risky.
I don't want a derivative
of a delta function.
I better keep it all over here.
So I'll have -cU'', times V.
This is what I had originally.
I just took the
equation, you remember
how we got these equations?
I just took the strong form,
multiplied by V, integrated,
and now I usually
integrated by parts,
but I'm backing off of that.
Because my V is too
singular to do it.
So again, what would I do?
My U would be a combination,
as always, of these.
And what will I get
for these integrals?
What will I get for
those integrals?
Well, of course, if
that's a delta function
at a mesh point, when
I integrate something
against a delta
function, I get--
What do I get when I integrate
against a delta function?
If V_i is the delta function
at a particular mesh point i,
as always I get the
value of that at i.
At i.
So I'll get -cU'' will
be whatever it is.
It will be the sum of
U_i's, the unknown constant,
times the phi_i double prime.
And what will I get on
the right-hand side?
When I integrate f times V_i?
I'll get f at that
mesh point, f_i.
In other words, I think what
I've got there is essentially
a difference equation.
I'm back pretty much
to finite differences.
I'm taking the value f, not
integrated now, but just
its value at i,
because that's what I
get when I do a delta function.
And I'm taking this.
Notice, a lot of things
are different here.
And there's a name for this.
This is called collocation.
I guess what I'm saying
is collocation, this idea,
is somewhere in between.
I'm interpolating -- collocation
-- between the finite element,
the Galerkin principle,
and finite differences,
where I don't even think
about trial functions.
In between is something
that really looks like--
[SOFT MUSIC] [LAUGHTER] I don't
know if that wonderful music
comes through on the
OpenCourseWare tape,
but anyway.
This is MIT.
We get a brass band here.
Okay, that would be a very
finite-difference-looking set
of equations to approximate the
original differential equation.
The point I want to
make, this gives me
a chance to make a point here.
Could I use hat functions?
Could I use hat functions in
this as my trial functions,
if I was not going to
integrate by parts?
When are hat functions allowed?
Because hat functions
have a jump in the slope.
Right?
Hat functions have
a jump in the slope.
Then my answer, you can
see it coming, is no.
Hat functions, they don't
have good second derivatives.
So I wanted to make that
point, also, for beam bending.
And let me make it.
So your question is
leading me to another topic
that I wanted to mention.
That hat functions, phi' is OK.
Phi double prime, second
derivatives of hat functions,
are basically, let me just
say it in a word, not OK.
So this is OK, this is for
second order equations.
Well, second order equations
have a second derivative.
Looking bad.
But when I integrate by parts--
After integration by parts.
And that's exactly
how we've used them.
We've used them for our
second order equation.
We integrated by parts.
We had terms like cu'--
c phi primes times V'.
First derivatives, no problem.
But not OK for
collocation, this method
that I've just spoken about.
Because we're not
integrating by parts.
Our test function V,
the delta, was not
smooth enough to move a
derivative over there.
And, now my additional
not OK, for bending.
So this is just bringing
us into today's lecture,
but maybe it completes a point.
So in bending we did
integrate by parts.
So what did we get?
Our bending weak form,
our fourth order equation
weak form.
Say u fourth
derivative equal f(x).
When I integrated
by parts twice,
you remember, I had
u fourth times a v,
times a test function, dx.
And my idea, so really
we're seeing it here
for the first time, was to
do two integrations by parts,
get two derivatives off
of u, put them onto v,
and maybe there's a
c(x) in here, too.
This was our
integral to be done.
That's the basic integral that
leads to all the entries of K.
But the trouble is-- So
that's in the bending problem.
In the fourth order
problem, our integrals
are going to look like that.
And we have to use functions
that are good enough.
So if I use hat functions,
they're not good enough.
Why's that?
If you suppose u
and v are the same,
then I'm integrating the
second derivative squared.
And what is the second
derivative, what's its square,
and what's the integral?
This is really
worth recognizing.
So suppose phi is the same as
v, and it's the hat function.
And if I want to
integrate some constant,
or some nice function times
phi'' times v'', what do I get?
What's the second derivative?
What's the first derivative
of my hat function?
It's up, right?
It's the first derivative.
So let me do phi'*v', is,
let me draw its graph.
The first derivative
is zero up to there,
then the first derivative
jumps up to something high,
up to the middle.
Then it drops to the negative.
And then it comes back to zero.
Right?
That's my first derivative.
I'm OK integrating that.
I'm OK squaring it
and integrating.
But the second derivative, if
I graph phi'', which will be
the same as v'', what's the
second derivative of that
function?
It's zero, and then what
is it at this point?
The derivative now?
Delta, right?
Spikes up.
Then nothing until this point.
At that point what happens?
Spikes down twice as far.
Really way down.
And then finally
there's a spike up.
Okay.
I can integrate spikes
times nice functions.
What I can't integrate
is a spike times a spike.
So the answer for
this integral is what?
It's infinite.
The integral is no good.
If I have a spike times a spike,
you see-- Delta functions,
I'm OK with a nice function,
f(x) times a delta, is OK.
But not OK for the integral of
delta of x times delta of x.
That's not OK.
That one is infinite.
That one is not in
our space of functions
that we can integrate.
OK.
So this is the difficulty
you meet with higher order
problems, is that
your functions, some
of the old functions that
worked fine, are no longer OK.
I need two derivatives.
Or I need to be
able to integrate
the second derivative squared.
It can have a jump, but
it can't have a spike.
So what functions
have we chosen?
How would we deal
with bending problems?
And I guess that'll probably
come, maybe quickly,
into Friday's lecture.
How would I do finite
elements for bending?
I'm not allowed to use
hats, so what will I use?
Do you remember that
construction, Monday?
Those cubics.
Remember those cubics, those
C^1 cubics would be OK.
Why's that?
Because they have a
continuous derivative.
They're one degree smoother
than hat functions.
These were C^0 hat functions.
And they were still C^0
when I put bubbles in there.
I had to get up to that
extra degree of smoothness,
this continuous slope.
Then I can take the
second derivative.
The second derivative
may have a jump.
Jumps are OK.
A jump in the second derivative
there and a jump there,
I can multiply two jump
functions and integrate.
So those C^1 cubics
that we constructed,
you remember at every
node I had two unknowns,
the height and the slope.
So there were two cubics
for each mesh point.
But the key idea was that they
had this extra continuity.
And let me just
say, looking ahead,
these splines that
are also coming Friday
have one more degree of freedom.
I'm sorry, one
more, there's C^2.
So splines, cubic splines
-- I'll just put it here
because it fits -- C^2 for cubic
splines, that's coming Monday.
That's functions that have
two continuous derivatives,
and the jump is in
the third derivative.
So those could be
used, well, they
could be used for
sixth order problems.
Of course we're never going
to see a sixth order problem.
I hope.
But they could be used there.
Or they could be used in
collocation for fourth order--
Well, could they be used
for fourth order problems?
I'm not sure.
Anyway, the more smoothness,
as I go up in the derivatives,
I have to get more smoothness
in all the finite element
constructions.
And it gets a lot harder.
Actually, I can do it in 1-D,
but it gets seriously hard
in two dimensions to figure
out function surfaces
that-- This is what CAD
is all about, actually.
Is figuring out, how do
you get smooth surfaces?
The whole CAD/CAM world of NURBS
and piecewise, rational things.
It's a very complicated
construction,
to get the shape of
some engineering piece
approximated, including
its curved boundary,
by smooth piecewise polynomials,
or piecewise something.
That whole world of CAD is
not trivial, to do that.
Well, OK, that's my speech.
You got me started
with your question.
Did I answer your
question in some way?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: It went
beyond your question.
Yes it did.
That's right.
These are things
that I may not have
time to develop in
Friday's lecture,
because I really have to
get on to two dimensions,
and gradients and divergences,
all that good stuff
has to start Monday.
So we'll see something
about splines Friday.
But the whole world
of different elements
is sort of interesting.
Actually, can I say one more
thing about the elements
that we've already constructed.
I want to say one more
point that occurs to me.
And then I really will
stop and answer questions.
This extra point occurred to me.
You remember our example
where we had hat functions,
and then we also had
bubble functions.
Right?
So where did the bubble go?
These were only C^0, hats plus
bubbles, plus parabola bubbles,
quadratic bubbles.
Parabola bubble functions.
So how did those go?
Between two mesh
points-- Sorry, I'd
better leave myself more
space for that bubble.
OK, so one of these
guys goes up, down.
One of these guys, another
hat goes up and down.
And then between two I threw
in a bubble function, like so.
Right?
So those were all in my list
of trial functions and test
functions.
Two kinds, hats and bubbles.
Now, that's all fine.
And we can do these integrals.
But one point I
sort of went past.
So let's call this phi left,
phi bubble, and phi right.
OK.
So my trial functions, my
approximate solution, U,
is going to be some
amount of that left hat,
some amount of the bubble,
some amount of the right hat.
And more functions
on other intervals.
Now, my point is
just a simple one.
When we only had hats, then U
and the coefficient of this hat
was exactly the value
of U at that mesh point.
Why was that?
Because all the other
hats were zero there.
So when I only had hats,
these U's, U left and U right,
were exactly the values of my
approximation at the nodes.
That's why it looked so much
like finite differences.
What I want to ask you is, so
if I take the halfway point
as the sort of mesh
point for the bubble,
what is the value of
U of my approximation,
at that halfway point?
I just want to plug
in halfway point,
evaluate everything
at the halfway point.
So I want to find U
at this halfway point.
Right there.
Do you see what's happening?
U bubble, what is U
bubble, or phi bubble
at the halfway point?
One.
The bubble goes up to
one at the halfway point.
So the coefficient that
multiplies it multiplies one.
And you think, ah.
You might think, all
right, that's the value
of my approximation
at the halfway point.
But that's wrong, correct?
What is the value
of my approximation
at the halfway point, here?
Well, this guy is not
zero at the halfway point.
This one is not zero.
This should have been R, sorry.
These hats are not zero there.
My basis is not
quite as beautiful.
It's not quite as beautiful,
because my trial functions
are not one trial
function per mesh point,
including halfway
points, as before.
No problem.
I can do all the integrals,
I can get the values,
I can solve KU=F to
find the weights.
And then I just have to remember
that my basis is not as perfect
as before, because
at that mesh point,
three functions
are contributing.
Probably I'm making this
sound like a big deal.
It isn't a big
deal, but you have
to remember that
that's the case,
that that coefficient
of the bubble
is not your solution
at that point.
You have to remember that the
left hat and the right hat
are also contributing
at that point.
Or I could rethink my
functions, and make them-- Now
that's the cool thing.
So that's the idea.
Just so you see that
I could do that.
Here is my left point,
here's my halfway point,
and here's my right point.
So I'm going to have the
same combinations, which
are the piecewise parabolas that
are continuous at the nodes.
Let me show it to you.
I could change from
hats and bubbles to,
I'll keep the bubble,
because that's
one at the halfway point.
That's good.
But I have to fix
those hat functions.
If I want the hat
functions to be focused--
If I want the phi left function,
I call that a hat function,
but it's going to change shape,
it won't be a conical hat.
If I want a phi
function, I want it
to be one at that point,
its own home point,
but what else do I want?
I want it to be zero there.
I don't want it to
contribute there,
if I want this perfection.
Or there.
So you see my hat, instead
of coming down like that
and being 1/2 at that
point, what shall I do?
I replace that hat
by some combination
of the hat and the bubble to
make a parabola that does that.
And of course, this other
way will be the same.
So that's not a hat anymore.
What name should I give it?
Anybody suggest a name?
It's sort of a hat.
Sombrero.
Sombrero. [LAUGHTER]
OK, so I now
have sombrero functions, right?
OK.
Good.
And there'll be a sombrero
function, instead of the hat,
it was replaced by a better hat.
Now what about the one here?
Just tell me, how
do I draw that one?
What's that function?
I'll do it with dashed
lines, it's zero,
it should be zero at its
nodes-- at the nodes that
are not its nodes.
So you see each one is going
to come down and back up.
Really, I'm just saying you
have the freedom to do this.
By using combinations
of those functions,
I get exactly the
same as combinations
of these functions.
The only difference is that with
these new sombrero functions--
So now I have a U left sombrero
times a phi left sombrero,
and a U bubble times its
own bubble, I didn't change.
And a U right sombrero times
its phi right sombrero.
And the only point is that,
at that halfway point,
what does this equal
at the halfway point?
It equals that.
Right.
I've just done a little
change of variables.
I've changed the
function, so that
would change its coefficients,
but it's still the same space
of test functions.
I didn't change that.
My space of test
functions, these
are all still
piecewise parabolas.
They always were piecewise
parabolas, but some of them
were straight parabolas.
Now they're more
interesting parabolas.
OK, that may be a point you
didn't think about, anyway.
But it shows you that in
constructing finite elements,
it's really what
combinations you
get, more than what
individual hats or not,
or sombreros you might use.
In other words, you could
use either of those.
If you use the hat
functions, then you
could build on easy integrals.
Those integrals would be a
little trickier, not seriously.
And then the solution would be
like a finite difference thing.
Every U would link
to a mesh point.
OK.
I'll leave that
and hope you guys
have some questions
about homework.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh,
a question about this?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah, when
I say better accuracy, when
I put the hats and
the bubbles together,
the improvement would
be noticed in between.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
These guys, you mean?
Well yeah.
I didn't change a thing.
The answer would
still be the same.
My capital U that would come
out would be no different.
It's just I've chosen
a different basis,
you could say, to represent it.
But there wouldn't
be any difference,
and it would still be-- So
what would be the accuracy now?
This is like a good review.
How close will U be
to the true solution?
Well, I've got up to
quadratic, second degree,
so I would expect h cubed error.
Because that's the
term I'm missing.
And that's the term that
the cubics would get.
Right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
The question is, why did
I pick-- So I had my hats.
I guess essentially,
I wanted to throw
in some additional
functions, the bubbles, that
would up the accuracy without
serious increase in work.
And the natural
construction was that one.
Yeah.
Then I got piecewise parabolas.
You look for a construction
of finite elements
that kind of comes out
neatly, and this one did.
There was another question.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh, these
parabolas would produce--
That's a good question.
Yeah, these parabolas would
produce a delta function
right there.
You see, they have
a jump in slope.
Even if they're parabolas,
they don't have smooth slope.
So this could not be used
for a bending problem.
Or let me say it a
little differently,
because people commit crimes.
I call them variational crimes.
People have tried.
You know, it's a
heck of a lot of work
to construct smoother
trial functions.
So people say, well, just
ignore that delta function.
Put it in anyway, integrate
elsewhere, and just skip
the delta function.
So that would be called
a nonconforming function.
There's a very famous way to
create nonconforming function.
And that's very hot
stuff, actually.
Professor Peraire and others in
Aero are world experts on that.
Those are called
discontinuous Galerkin.
Discontinuous Galerkin.
This is fun.
You see what this
world is about.
So what's
discontinuous Galerkin?
Those will be ones where
there's a jump in the function.
Here I don't need
much space to show
you discontinuous Galerkin.
So there's a mesh point,
there's a mesh point.
Discontinuous Galerkin
might do this.
Oh no, not there.
That's continuous, sorry.
Discontinuous Galerkin would use
half hats inside the interval.
It would use that one.
And then another
one it would use
would be one that
jumped this way.
In other words, it sticks
within an interval,
it uses two functions
instead of one.
There are two unknowns.
Do you see what's happening now?
My space of trial functions
is going to have jumps.
Up to now, all my good hat--
my ordinary hat functions
were all continuous.
They were all C zero.
Now I'm dropping
back to C minus 1.
Somehow my functions have jumps.
So this is called DG,
discontinuous Galerkin.
And how could it be justified?
I mean, right?
These are functions--
Now I've got
a function that's not allowed
in my second order problem.
Right?
If I looked at my
list here, what was OK
and what was not OK, if I
look at interior half hats,
if I look at functions
that have a jump,
jump functions, shall
I say, jump functions.
Those would be C^(-1),
jump functions.
And phi' is not OK.
So I won't tell you, and I
wouldn't be able to do it well,
how do they rescue that?
However Professor Peraire
and others, others,
Professor Darmofal, a
whole group in Aero,
computing with functions
that have jumps.
And the way they
manage to do it is,
they have to add some
penalty term that
penalizes the jumps,
that controls the jumps.
If they just took
the standard set up,
as we have, and tried
their functions,
it would fail completely.
So they adjust the
energy to penalize jumps.
Anyway, somebody
might sometime end up
working on some
project with them,
and DG would be very possible.
So you didn't ask me about
any homework problems yet.
Last chance.
Anything to ask about?
You got a lecture about
crazy stuff today.
Sorry about that, in a way,
but I hope it was all right.
So homework is now posted,
with a MATLAB question using
the elements that we've talked
about and some questions
from the text.
And don't forget, then,
my original comment
that if we end up with some
good codes for CSE that
could be used by other people,
I'm very grateful to get them.
OK.
Let's end today a little
early, and I'll see you Friday
for splines.